hey what's up guys marquez from mkbhd
here and today we are back with android
4.0 already available on our asus
transformer prime the tablet that we
love so much and has the tegra 3 quad
core processor a little bit surprising
that it's here before uh the beloved
motorola zoom uh google's very own the
first honeycomb tablet so without any
further ado let's go ahead and take a
look at the interface the experience the
new features and just how much faster
ics makes this tablet make sure you give
a thumbs up on this video for the quad
core android goodness and also it really
does help out a lot thanks for watching
let's go alright so welcome to tablet
view and of course the first thing we
can take a look at an ice cream sandwich
is the beautiful lock screen which as we
saw on the galaxy nexus has direct
access to the camera software and this
is the updated camera software as we can
see in ice cream sandwich we have these
beautiful new menus here
and uh we also from the lock screen can
just unlock you can see here we have the
new pagination icons up top and ice
cream sandwich is looking beautiful and
smooth as ever in order to see what
version of ice cream sandwich you have
you can go to these settings here
and if we scroll down to about tablet we
are running android 4.0.3 so if we can
tap that a whole bunch of times i think
we can activate the easter egg
maybe yeah this is the uh
the beautiful ice cream sandwich nyan
cat we saw on the galaxy nexus i don't
know why that's so entertaining to me
but anyway um in order to get this
stock ice cream sandwich settings you
can go into your settings and go to asus
customize setting and uncheck this is
the uh the stock settings we had before
it's a little bit ugly in my opinion so
i unchecked it and now we have the stock
ice cream sandwich settings which i
think is beautiful and that brings us
back here to uh the fonts we see
everywhere and that's roboto of course
the the font that's introduced and we
see on the nexus is back here in this
and it's looking beautiful as ever with
roboto
now the responsiveness as we saw here is
also very much uh still amazing
performance is improved with the
multitasking see how fast that is right
when i tap that boom multitasking just
comes up instantly and we can actually
swipe off apps to kill them and that
actually kills the application so let's
say i have calendar open here
and i go back home and i open up
calendar it's immediately right there
now i'll go ahead and kill the calendar
and open up again you'll see it has to
reload the whole calendar so now we have
true multitasking here with android
4.0.3 and that is beautiful we also have
the new app drawer up here so we can see
that nice little swipe animation as they
fade in which is also again started on
the nexus and we can swipe over here to
widgets and now we have all our widgets
here that we can add to our home screens
this is all very very smooth and easy
we'll go ahead and add our power control
widget over here on this home screen
as you can see goes up just like that
and uh you know all the functionality
still has that cyan color which is nice
and beautiful also it has a new ability
to add folders so as you can see here i
have two different apps next to each
other if they're outside of our folder i
can drag it on top and they create a new
folder that we can name i'll name it cam
like i had before and i have a new
google folder which actually has a
couple of the updated ice cream sandwich
apps yes gmail was updated for ics so it
looks all pretty now very very very
professional looking actually we also
have a brand new gallery and that pulls
down all our photos from google plus of
course so it looks looks good and of
course we have a good wi-fi connection
it'll look really good so there you go
and we actually do have the new people
app now and it looks like tablet
optimized so that's good that we have
all our different uh people in there you
won't be seeing that phone number will
you but yeah you can see uh performance
is very much still extremely fast on the
galaxy nexus i did try quadrant but of
course it's not ice cream sandwich
optimized yet so that's not really a big
deal but yeah let me guys know what you
guys think of ice cream sandwich in the
comments down below i think it's a great
upgrade i was personally excited to see
this on friday but thank gosh it's
finally here so yeah this is looking
really good i'm excited to keep using
this and you'll see a review of the
transformer prime pretty soon as i get
used to it
the battery life just so you know so far
has been outstanding absolutely
phenomenal either way thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're taking a look at android 4.0 on
the ace
probably not a good idea
delete